Let's go to an international caller.
I think let's go to the person who's calling
from country code 57 who's calling from country
code 57
hello?
Is this me?
That is you.
Yeah.
What's your name?
Where you're calling from?
Hi.
Um, my name is also David and I'm calling
from Columbia.
Oh, hey, we're in Colombia.
Okay.
And the capital cities.
But what that,
oh, cool.
My Dad was just there a couple of months ago.
Okay.
Oh, good to know.
Yeah.
So I think recently, Washington watching your
show and first of all, good job on, on your
container.
I'm a watcher of yours.
Great.
Yeah.
So my question is this, let's say the Bernie
Sanders won the Democratic primary, eh?
Who, who do you think should be here?
Vice President Tech.
No idea too early to, to to, to think about,
I'm trying to avoid, I'm, I'm trying to take
these things one step at a time when it was
2017 and people were saying who should run
for the Democrats in 2020, we got to deal
with 2018 first.
Similarly, we haven't even had a single debate
yet.
Um, and I think before we can figure out who
the running mate should be, we've got to at
least see a couple of debates and see where
everybody is.
What do you, do you have a strong feeling?
Who Do you think uh, the vice presidential
candidate should be if Bernie is the nominee?
Well, Elizabeth Warren,
why do you like them?
Well, Elizabeth Warren, because she is proposing
almost the same.
Bernie is and with the Ebay are running together,
they can become a, like the dream team flow
of sores and Toci Gabbert is because of her
international, her international policies.
She is strong in that and she can help up
Bernie in that because that's his weakness
from what I can see.
In what way is Bernie Week on international
policy.
Okay.
Well and that I'm pointing, not sure.
I just think that in the thing of the droning
system and in the joining other countries
that I think that's, that's the main problem.
I'm not sure about that.
Okay, so what, what did Bernie say about droning?
Yeah, I really don't.
Oh Man.
I
yeah, specific in mind that that's fine.
We'll listen.
I think that um, there is going to be plenty
of time to figure out who the right running
mate is for whoever the eventual nominee is.
I think you're making the case, for example,
with Elizabeth Warren that because reviews
are similar to Bernie's, she would be a good
pic.
That's one perspective.
The other perspective would be you want someone
who actually differs from Bernie in others
in order to appeal to more wings of the Democratic
Party.
I Dunno, I'm sort of taking a back seat and
waiting before I take a position on that.
Oh, okay.
Good to know.
All right.
We've gotten from Columbia.
Really appreciate it.
Hope to hear from you again.
Okay.
All right, great.
Take care.
Thank you so much for the call.